on a beaucoup parlé du sort des caribous
dans l'est du pays mais dans l'Ouest
canadien les populations sont également
déclin et là-bas aussi la destruction de
leur habitat est montrée du doigt
heureusement il y a parfois une rare
lueur d'espoir
[Musique]
dans le nord-est de la Colombie
Britannique les pics des montagnes wild
heart s'élance vers le ciel
territoire habité par les peuples denisa
crient et surtout depuis des temps
immémoriaux la légende veut qu'ils aient
été attirés ici par une vision celle des
deux sœurs aujourd'hui un site sacré
à l'ombre du sommet du mont Rockford à
2000 mètres d'altitude
stargotier veille sur une vingtaine de
caribous d'une valeur inestimable
tout au long de l'année pour l'année ici
nourrir les filles se fit dès que je
il y a à peine quelques années le
caribou avait disparu presque
complètement de ses contrées
mais grâce à Star et à son équipe le
cervidé
iconique fait un retour en force ici que
peu de gens auraient cru possible
on a enfin décidé d'agir et les chiffres
augmentent c'est un succès et je suis
fier de contribuer
les caribous parcouraient autrefois ces
forêts ces montagnes par milliers
[Musique]
aussi nombreux que les moustiques il y
en avait partout sur le territoire
mais l'équilibre naturel était respecté
on prenait ce dont on avait besoin pour
survivre pas plus et on utilisait tout
de l'animal oui
mais tout a basculé selon le chef Wilson
au milieu du 20e siècle les barrages
érigés sur la rivière la paix entre
autres ont dissimmé les troupeaux
[Musique]
derrière nous mais quand la région a été
inondée il ne pouvait plus traverser
un morcellement depuis il est caribou
forme de petit arbre
les Premières nations ont mis fin à la
chaste subsistance dans les années 70
mais le déclin se poursuit si bien qu'en
2013 le troupeau clinziza qui avait
longtemps soutenu les peuples
autochtones ne comptez plus que 16
caribou
nous devions agir il se serait fait
décimer complètement par des loups
les Premières nations ouest
et lynj biologiste leur domaine
d'expertise c'est la conservation de
population de grands mammifères
le couple propose une approche
ambitieuse mais risqué
à une centaine de kilomètres dans la
montagne dans un secteur de l'arrière
pays rocailleux et difficile d'accès il
faut construire un enclos
érigé autour d'un terrain et de 14
hectares à l'état sauvage un endroit où
les femelles peuvent mettre bas en toute
sécurité et où les vos prennent des
forces loin des prédateurs
la première année il restait vraiment
peu de bêtes la dernière chose qu'on
voulait c'était bien entendu de les
mettre encore plus en danger en les
amenant ici
[Rires]
10 femelles en gestation sont capturés
en mars 2014 à l'aide d'un filet
déployés des heures
elles sont transportées par hélicoptère
puis entraîne au dans la forêt boréale
jusqu'à l'enclos
pour les réveiller et puis on les laisse
aller dans l'enclos
[Musique]
naissent en enclos au printemps 2014 il
faut ensuite les protéger contre les
prédateurs deux clôtures électriques
sont érigés autour de l'enclos monitory
par un réseau de caméra
jour et nuit les membres des Premières
nations garde un œil sur leur précieux
locataire
je prends mon fusil et je fais le tour
de l'enclos matin et soir il faut les
protéger des grizzly qui pourraient
entrer ici et faire des dégâts cet
espace appartient au caribou il faut les
protéger comme ils nous ont protégés par
le passé
et c'est une chose qui tient réveillé la
nuit aussi quand on quand j'ai un texte
sur mon cellulaire c'est son genre le
soir ça vient d'ici c'est toujours ok
c'est quoi le problème
tout récemment à la caméra le prix une
photo du carcajou entre les deux
clôtures ça a été une grosse surprise
qu'est-ce qui serait arrivé ici le
carcajou a décidé de rentrer dans
l'enclos on veut pas y penser
[Musique]
en nous les femelles et leurs veaux sont
relâchés pour aller rejoindre le
troupeau dans la nature
[Musique]
la première année ne s'est pas très bien
terminée on est libéré les veaux à
seulement 6 semaines et les prédateurs
en ont tué plusieurs deux seulement en
survécu
importante leçon il faut les garder plus
longtemps dans l'enclos
naissent en enclos et presque tous
survivent jusqu'au printemps suivants
le caribou des montagnes du sud est une
sous-espèce du caribou des bois qui
s'étend de Terre-Neuve jusqu'au Yukon on
le retrouve surtout dans le centre et le
sud de la Colombie Britannique des
populations menacées selon le registre
fédéral des espèces en péril
[Musique]
Robert cyruya étudie ce service des
depuis une vingtaine d'années
la transformation du paysage perdue mais
selon lui mais en péril la survie de
dizaines de troupeaux
par l'industrie forestière c'est créer
comme des autoroutes pour les loups et
les cougars alors ça augmente l'accès
dans des zones où il y avait pas d'accès
pour les prédateurs avant
c'est foret anciennes c'est un habitat
très important pour les caribous il y a
beaucoup de lichens dans ces arbres
surtout un peu plus haut dans la
montagne alors ça ça donne la nourriture
au carré bout mais c'est forêts sont
tous si d'un grand intérêt pour les
compagnies forestières quand on fait les
coupes du blanc ça stimule la croissance
des nourritures pour les orignaux et les
cerfs et cela attire les loups et le
caribou devient une proie de coïncidence
de ces extinctions ces animaux
disparaissent sous nos yeux nous
devrions tous nous sentir concernés moi
ça m'empêche de dormir
la
biologisteb étudie l'impact de l'humain
sur la faune et la flore
il y a d'énormes de coupes à blanc comme
ça partout en Colombie-Britannique le
caribou perd de plus en plus d'habitats
chaque année ses trajets
[Musique]
en 2019 elle lance un projet de
recherche visant à identifier les
copains dans la vitesse essentiel du
caribou
les cartes qu'elle publie démontre que
les copains se font partout dans ces
secteurs
elle conclut que plus de 100000 hectares
d'habitat essentiels ont été décimés par
l'activité forestière en 5 ans soit deux
fois la taille de l'île de Montréal
j'étais horrifiée parce qu'il se passait
et en colère c'est une espèce en voie de
disparition nous savons où se trouve son
habitat le plus important et nous en
autorisons la destruction pas étonnant
que les populations ne se rétablissent
pas
[Musique]
parmi la trentaine de Hard de caribou
des montagnes du sud 5 seulement sont
stables 14 sont en déclin et cette
troupeau ont disparu complètement dont 3
depuis 2016
en 2020 il ne restait que 3100 caribou
dans ses troupeaux une baisse de 50 % en
6 ans seulement
le gouvernement de la
Colombie-Britannique affirme de son côté
que 2 millions d'hectares d'habitats
essentiels du caribou ont été protégés
depuis 20 ans il suspendra également les
coupes de bois sur 2 millions d'hectares
supplémentaires de forêts anciennes
mais la province soutient qu'il est
important de garantir un certain accès
aux compagnies forestières même dans les
secteurs les plus critiques à la survie
du caribou l’économie en dépend une
réponse désolante selon
la même chose depuis des décennies si on
veut être le moindrement sérieux et
sauver cette espèce il faut protéger son
habitat il n'y a plus de temps à perdre
quelques troupeaux de caribous sont tout
de même en expansion surtout grâce à la
mise à mort de centaines de loups depuis
quelques années mais celui qui croit à
la vitesse grand V c'est le troupeau
géré par les nations Soto et westmogly
le succès de l'enclos de maternité
jumelé au contrôle des populations Blue
a été remarquable le troupeau Klin Ziza
est passé de 16 bêtes en 2013 à environ
140 caribous en 2023
[Musique]
de réussir et que ça marche c'est
fantastique mais reste que c'est enclos
est une mesure invasive qui ne devrait
pas être nécessaire ce qui leur nuit le
plus c'est le développement industriel
à cet effet les membres des Premières
nations ont conclu en 2020 une entente
historique avec la province pour
protéger un million 700000 hectares de
leur territoire ancestral contre le
développement industriel soit trois fois
la superficie de l'Île du Prince
eldouard des secteurs compromis par
l'activité minière et forestière sont
aussi réhabiliter
ces deux approches permettront d’éviter
l'abattage de louer l'aménagement dans
le clos de maternité on ne devrait pas
avoir besoin de telle mesure pour
assurer la survie des populations
une question s'impose le succès des
mesures entreprises par les nations Soto
et ouest pour être reproduit ailleurs
dans la province
la mise sur pied d'un enclos de
maternité coûte très cher sans compter
la gestion quotidienne
mais surtout la volonté politique
est-elle suffisante
[Musique]
les enclos de maternité ne sont pas une
solution viable pour les caribous si le
gouvernement est l'industrie ne
protègent pas l'habitat
2022 a été la meilleure année à date du
projet d'enclaude maternité 16 veaux ils
sont nés et ont depuis rejoint le
troupeau
une douzaine de veaux sont au cinés à
l'extérieur de l'enclos dans la nature
une étape essentielle vers
l'autosuffisance
est convaincu Kylian plus grande leçon à
tirer de la réussite du projet
suivez notre exemple
tous cette terre nourricière et faisons
partie de l'écosystème
[Musique]